من التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث وافادتها القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه بتعرض مناطق جنوب شرقي البلاد
خصوصا مقاطعه الزبولوجيا لهجوم الروسيه
بمسيارات ايرانيه الصنع اطلقت من الساحل
الشرقي لبحر ازوف واضافت ان 13 مسيره شنت
الهجوم لافته الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
تمكنت من اسقاط عشر منها بينما اصابت ثلاث
سيارات اهدافها على حد تعبيرها وقالت
الاداره العسكريه في زبوجيا ان شخصين قتل
واصيب ثلاثه في قصف صاروخي ومدفعين قال
سته عشره مدينه وبلده في المقاطعه وذكرت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه استخدمت صواريخ موجهه مضاده
للطائرات اصابت عددا من المنشات العسكريه
والبنيه التحتيه في المنطقه للمتابعه في
هذا الموضوع معنا منخر كيف مراسل الجزيره
حسان مسعود كما ينضم الينا من دنياسك
مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي حسان ابدا معك
اذا الجبهه الشرقيه ما زالت مشتعله والان
تركيز على
ما حجم المخاوف هناك من اي استهداف لمحطه
زبولوجيا النوويه وكيف يبدو الوضع عموما
في هذه المنطقه
سهام بالفعل لا التطورات متواصله على عدد
من الجبهات بشكل متزامن هنا في الجبهه
الشرقيه يتواصل القصف على مناطق ومدن
وبلدات عمق الجبهه بالاضافه الى المناطق
الواقعه على طول شريط هذه الجبهه من هنا
من خارك كانت هذه الليله ليله صاخبه دوت
الانفجارات والقصف في عدد من المناطق في
جنوب شرقي مقاطعه وكذلك في مدينه كوبينس
المنطقه التي باتت جبهه مشتعله منذ انسحاب
القوات الروسيه منها في سبتمبر الماضي
وكذلك التطورات كانت متواصله على طول
الجبهه في المنطقه الشرقيه في محيط طباخ
موت وكذلك في المدن والبلدات الواقعه في
عمق هذه الجبهه منطقه بخورات تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه ان واحد وثلاثين اشتباكا وقع
في المنطقه الشرقيه في منطقه ضخم التحديدا
وكذلك في مناطق
بالاضافه الى منطقه ليمن شماليه تلك
المقاطعه هذه التطورات ايضا تتزامن مع
تطورات في المنطقه والجبهه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه كما اشرت في سهام تلك المنطقه
منطقه
الهجمات التي تصفها اوكرانيا بالهجمات
المضاده في تلك المقاطعه بالاضافه الى
جنوب مقاطعه دنيتك القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
انها ما زالت تواصل محاوله التقدم في تلك
الجبهه الا ان القوات الروسيه كثفت من
ضرباتها على مدينه زابولوجيا بشكل خاص هذه
الليله تقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا
تقول ان القوات الروسيه قصفتها باربع
صواريخ اس 300 وجهت نحو المنشات البنيه
التحتيه وهي منشات تعني بذلك المنشات
العسكريه في منطقه
زابولوجيا بالاضافه ايضا الى ضرب عدد من
المواقع على طول الجبهه وادى ذلك الى مقتل
عدد من الاشخاص يضاف الى ذلك حديث
الاوكراني عن خطر المستمر عند
محطه النوويه هذا الخطر القوات الاوكرانيه
والرئاسه الاوكرانيه وعدد من المسؤولين
يتحدثون عنه منذ فتره طويله لا يشيرون
بشكل واضح الى طبيعه الخطر الى ما سيحدث
في هذه المحطه لكنهم يتهمون الجانب الروسي
بانهم من الممكن ان يفخخوا محطه زابولوجيا
ولكن هذا الحديث بات يرتفع بوثيرته خلال
الايام الاخيره واخيرا اليوم الماضي فقط
في منطقه زابولوجيا واختم بذلك قامت
القوات الاوكرانيه بتنفيذ مناورات عمليه
وواقعيه لمثل هذا الخطر ما يعني ان الخطر
يزداد يوما بعد الاخر في ظل تصاعد الحديث
عنه شكرا جزيلا لك حس